closures a closure is the combination of
a function and the environment within
which that function was declared the
environment consists of any local
variables that were in scope at the time
that the closure was created in
JavaScript all functions form closures
in other languages without closures the
local variables within a function only
exist for the duration of that functions
execution let's look at an example so we
have this function make func and we have
the var name equals Jas Nuggets and then
we have another function within the
function display name where we're going
to console dot log the name and this
function make func is going to return to
display name the other function so down
here we're going to create the my func
equals make func which is we're making a
variable that's this function and we're
going to run my funk now it's going to
return display name now if we run that
it's going to display J's Nuggets so
it's returning this function inside that
function there is no name but because of
closures this function that's been rich
that's being returned and run here has
access to the environment with that was
created in which means it had access to
this J's nuggets the name variable even
though this the name is even in here so
that's basically what a closure is so
the function has access to any variable
that's within the scope or the
environment that was created in now
let's look at some more some more
practical examples a closure lets you
associate some data which is the
environment with a function that
operates on that data one way to use a
closure is to emulate private methods
private methods can only be called by
other methods in the same class but
JavaScript does not have a native way of
doing this it is possible to emulate
private methods with closures okay let's
look at this we've of our counter and
this is assigned to an anonymous
function and here's the anonymous
function right here and as soon as the
anonymous function is assigned its
executed as soon as it's been defined
these two parentheses that then is we
are going to execute that function and
put the execution of that function into
the variable counter and the so it's
going to return when it executes the
function is going to return this into
the variable counter so this is actually
first going to create a shared
environment and then it's going to send
out some things into the variable
counter so the shared environment
involves the private VAR private counter
0 and the function change by value which
is private counter and it's going to add
the value and then assign the added
value to private counters it's going to
increase private counter by the value so
then we're going to return these
functions and because these functions
have been returned into the counter you
are only going to be able to access
these functions from outside of the
counter so these are going to be private
and these are going to be the public
methods so we're returning the increment
function will change by one it calls
change by one and see this increment
method that's being created can access
the change by method because it's in the
environment that was created in this
decrement can access the change by
because it's in the environment that's
created and and this value can return
the private counter their look exists
within the environment was created in so
neither the private items can be
accessed directly from outside of the
anonymous function but they can just be
accessed by the three public functions
that are returned from the anonymous
wrapper these are the public functions
thanks to Java Script lexical scoping
they each have access to the private
counter variable entertained by function
so let's see this in action we're going
to console dialogue counter that value
counter dot value and then we're going
to increment it we're going to increment
again they're going to counter that log
count of console that log it again then
we're going to decrement
council that log so let me run this and
see the first time the counter is 1:0
attitude increments it's two and then we
decrement next one well thanks for
watching I hope this gave you a good
introduction to closures my name is Bo
Carnes and if you check the description
you can look for some links that where
you can get some more information about
closures including a link where I got a
lot of information for this video please
subscribe and remember use your code for
good